[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Marvel Eternals video
there been a bunch of things happening
with the movie bunch of announcements
that Marvel is made what's going on with
the characters some of them are going to
be crossing over with future Avengers
movies so we'll break it all down if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing a new Amazon giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave all your theories about the movie
on the video I know that a lot of
questions about what's going on with
Marvel's release schedule this year
because a lot of things have been
delayed what are we gonna see the first
Eternals trailer so we'll also try to
explain that during the video to
Marvel's using the movie is a sort of
ancient history lesson on the MCU where
everything came from the dawn of the
universe the Infinity stones the
Celestials eternity so we'll talk about
some of the other really cool Easter
eggs and things that they'll show while
they're telling the history of the MCU
starting with number 10 most of you know
at least a little bit about the Eternals
even if you haven't read those comic
books I will explain which eternals
comic book the movie's going to be based
on but the quick explainer is that
they're just a race of ancient humans
that were modified by Celestials to
become superhumans
there was a marble Eternals comic-con
trailer that they screened at the end of
last year in some footage I did a
breakdown video of that where I talked a
little bit about the design language of
their costumes you know it seems like a
lot of the modern-day costumes from the
present-day
MCU heroes are inspired by a lot of
their Eternals costume designs so the
movie will try to show you how they've
influenced the culture and really
interesting ways and all the other MCU
movies sort of linking this all together
there are really only three main
characters in the movie though even
though there are a ton of characters
that they've shown you so far there's
kit harington's Black Knight he's not
one of the Eternals he's just a normal
human in present day there's Richard
Madden's Icarus and Jimmy Chan's Cersei
there was a very notable black knight
Easter egg during spider-man far from
home when they're in the Tower of London
that big final battle scene when they're
all rushing into the Tower of London to
hide from Mysterio's drones you can
actually see them pass by a suit of
armor designed to look like the classic
Black Knights armor
[Music]
the really cool thing about his
character is that it's actually a title
that's passed down through his family so
the real name of kit harington's Black
Knight is Dane Whitman the Whitman
family has this lineage that goes all
the way back to King Arthur in the
knights of the round table in Merlin
Merlin forged the ebony blade gave it to
the Black Knights ancestor he became the
first black knight the really cool thing
about the sword itself it does carry a
curse but it's sort of like kit
harington's version of Stormbreaker he
can use it to teleport the same way Thor
uses Stormbreaker to open the Bifrost
when he's wielding the ebony blade he
almost becomes unkillable he can still
be injured but he can't be killed the
terrible curse that it carries though is
that the more people he kills with the
ebony blade the thirstier and thirstier
the blade gets until he's eventually
overcome with bloodlust and becomes a
blood wraith a lot of you asking which
of these characters are gonna cross over
into future Avengers movies or other big
Marvel movies so 8th Kevin Feige also
revealed back at d23 kit harington's
black knight would have the
quote-unquote opportunity to appear in
bigger Avengers level movies like
Avengers 5 we just heard Kit Harington
yes is a really amazing actor and this
part came up in the Eternals film that
we're doing we were so happy when he
agreed to join and it is a part that
could perhaps grow into something else
in the future Marvel jumped on him the
minute after he ended the main game of
Thrones series they didn't say how many
movies Kit Harington had signed on for
in the MCU but the reason why the Black
Knight would join an Avengers team is
that he and Cersei had a relationship in
the comics eventually they joined the
Avengers for a big period
there's even supposed to be some sort of
love triangle happening between kit
harington's Black Knight character
Cersei and Icarus as Richard Madden so
make all the Game of Thrones jokes about
Robb Stark and Jon Snow fighting over a
character named Cersei number seven kid
Harrington's Black Knight character is
not part of the Marvel comic book story
that they're basing the movie on so the
movies always changed the comics just a
little bit but the main story that the
movie is borrowing from is Neil Gaiman
2006 a Turtles comic book if you're big
Neil Gaiman fan or you're a big Eternals
fan Marvel actually did a whole animated
miniseries based on that comic book
it was literally page to screen copy
paste adaptation the reason
either using that story is because it
does a really good job in a short time
span of telling the history of the
Eternals and what's going on with the
characters in present day and why they
weren't around for Avengers infinity war
and Avengers endgame if they have
godlike powers wouldn't they have helped
out during avengers endgame in that big
final battle but what happened in the
comics is one of the Eternals went rogue
and erased all of their memories so they
all just forgot that they were basically
living gods on planet earth so you have
a bunch of them leading normal lives in
present day when everybody's getting
snapped during Avengers infinity war and
then coming back in Avengers endgame the
fact that so much cosmic energy was
given off when all those snaps happened
is what causes some of the Eternals to
start remembering who they are and where
they came from that's why some of the
movie is going to be said in present day
in 2023 after the events of Avengers end
game number 6 some of the movies going
to take place tens of thousands of years
ago telling the ancient history of the
MCU in the Marvel cosmic universe the
Eternals were created by the Celestials
the Celestials were created by eternity
so they had to explain all that cosmic
history before they can start explaining
who the Eternals are there been a couple
Easter eggs hinting at this in previous
Marvel movies like you have the
guardians of the galaxy scene where the
collector is explaining the history of
the Infinity stones and you get a little
bit of the history of the Celestials
number 5 as part of that history lesson
a lot of new sites recently have started
reporting that we're going to see the
sinking of Atlantis happen while they're
doing the montage explaining the history
of the MCU they kind of did a version of
that during the Aquaman movie showing
you Atlantis sinking because it's such a
big location for that character Namor
isn't supposed to show up during the
Eternals movie so I don't think that
Atlantis is gonna be a big location or
anything like that you remember the
Black Panther movie at the beginning
they had a bit of a history lesson for
vibranium in Wakanda during that
vibranium history lesson there are also
a lot of Easter eggs for other MCU
characters and movies like you see all
the world war ii stuff happening big
Easter Egg for Captain America going
down in the ice if Atlantis did show up
during the Eternals movie it'd be
something like that just an easter egg
in the background just paying off that
Iron Man 2 Easter Egg where it sits on
the map and the Avengers endgame Easter
Egg with the quote-unquote underwater
earthquake number
or a lot of you've also been asking me
about how the Eternals movie is going to
explain mutants and x-men in the
modern-day MCU and set that up
there's been a lot of talk about this
online since the movie was first
announced the big x-men characters
aren't really supposed to start showing
up till Marvel phase five so it's still
a ways off what Marvel is doing these
next few years with the Marvel phase
four movies it's just creating the
backstory necessary so that it all makes
sense when Marvel says hey all these big
x-men characters like Wolverine
Professor X magneto storm they've been
around this whole time we just haven't
seen them till now there was a very
recent Marvel comic book that gave a
much more specific answer about this
saying that it was celestial blood
tainting Earth's soil that created the X
gene and then eventually the X gene led
to the proliferation of mutants that's
not the only way that they're going to
introduce mutants in the MCU but expect
the MCU version to be much simpler
number three because we have the
multiverse we have Doctor Strange to the
multiverse of madness coming up the one
division Scarlet Witch Disney Plus
series one division is really like the
next big thing that's going to introduce
the concept of mutants and biological
powers in the MCU because Scarlet Witch
is a very powerful mutant from the
comics but they've always had to dance
around that in the MCU movies now they
don't have to do that anymore number two
a lot of you also asking about a young
version of Thanos may be showing up
during future Eternals movies Thanos is
an eternal who was born on Titan so we
saw Titan during Avengers infinity war
there was even an Avengers infinity war
deleted scene that we got concept art
for with a young version of Thanos with
his family this is what he would have
looked like had this appeared during the
movie Josh Brolin said that he wants to
come back his young fan OHS he said that
he also wants to come back as cable
inside the MCU through the Deadpool
movies so what I'm hoping is is that
eventually they'll save his birth for
the final Eternals movie if they can
make it to a trilogy in number one
everyone wants to know when is the movie
coming out has it been affected by
delays Marvel hasn't made any changes to
its Eternals release date plans but
that's only because the movie was coming
out of November and I think all the
movie studios are kind of hoping that
most of the trouble with all the
shutdowns will be done by the end of the
summer by August or September they have
enough finished footage in effects for
trailer so where is the first Marvel
Eternals trailer originally it would
have dropped with
Black Widow movie at the beginning of
May but now because the Black Widow
movie has been delayed and they have not
announced a new release date yet right
now they're just waiting to find out
when they're going to actually release
Black Widow then they'll also release
the Eternals trailer with that at least
a couple months before the movie comes
out
so even though normally you would get it
six months before the movie comes out it
might not come til this summer there's
been a lot of talk about Black Widow
being released video-on-demand I'm gonna
wait a little bit longer to see what the
studio's say about that before I make a
video but I will post an update video as
soon as they announce something everyone
let me know in the comments what do you
want my next big Marvel video to be
about everyone click here for my brand
new black panther to preview video and
click here for my brand new Marvel
Weapon X video thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]